treasury secretary Janet Yellen has just
made a trip to the 51st state you know
what I'm talking about Ukraine
Janet Yellen made this unannounced visit
to Ukraine yesterday and she did so to
support the nation's war effort against
Russia and also to bring Mr zielinski a
lot of money
all the reporting it said Janet Yellen
showed up to support the nation's war
effort against Russia my question was
which nations
Ukraine's effort against Russia is
Ukraine really a nation exactly or with
the visits from
top CIA brass to Ukraine over in recent
years with visits from the president of
the United States with visits from Janet
Yellen
kind of seems like Ukraine is just a
part of our nation or maybe that Ukraine
is just a part of our Empire and what
we're seeing here play out is an
imperial war between the United States
and Russia over a buffer state which
Russia invaded
Janet Yellen says
that she was there to quote discuss
critical economic assistance and our
efforts to hold Russia accountable for
their illegal and brutal War
to reaffirm U.S support for Ukraine
and to give them 1.25 billion dollars
from a nearly 10 billion tranche of Aid
to Ukraine
she says America will stand with Ukraine
as long as it takes
I think this is much more efficient than
what we've been doing recently which is
we've been sending different aids to
Ukraine or we sent yesterday a few days
ago we sent the president of the United
States but I think it's much more
efficient if we send the treasury
secretary because she's in charge of the
money so let's just cut out the middle
man let's get all that money going over
to Ukraine I actually this year as we
prepare our taxes I think I'm going to
include Vladimir zielinski as a
dependent on my tax forms if if we're
going to fund the War I at the very
least want to get some marginal tax
benefit from it my other question is
how easy is it to fly into Ukraine
I thought there was this bloody war it
was going to be World War III this is
the worst war zone in the world and yet
everybody flies in there you've got all
these world leaders the president of the
United States the treasury secretary a
few days later I don't know it just that
seems a little discordant to me I I'm
not quite sure although I guess it was
ever thus the United States this isn't
just a Biden problem the United States
for well over a hundred years
has owned Imperial territories and
conducted
the business of Empire and and that's
what we're doing now in Ukraine and so
we can either whine about it and say
that's not how the Constitution was set
up or whatever or we just recognize
that's exactly what it is and we cut out
all the
silly Gobbledy book about all sorts of
abstractions and liberalism and
democracy and we say that's what we're
fighting
we are claiming some territory here and
we want to we believe it's in the
American national interest for Ukraine
to be on our side not on Russia's side a
little skeptical of that Imperial
expansion but the liberals who run our
country and who effectively run the
American Empire
they're all in and they've been all in
for many many decades now speaking of
Foreign Affairs
we covered yesterday this this new
Breaking report
this new conclusion out of the energy
Department that it turns out
covid very likely came from a laboratory
in Wuhan not from the Wuhan wet Market
that's what the energy department has
concluded that's what some other
agencies of the US government have
concluded just wanted to take you on a
little trip down memory lane
uh
to the media's reaction to that theory
just a few years ago
because we don't know where the novel
coronavirus came from yet the conspiracy
theories filled a void Chinese
researchers have already determined the
coronavirus is 96 percent identical at
the whole genome level to a bat
Coronavirus
27 Public Health scientists from across
the U.S and the world wrote this letter
in the journal Lancet condemning
conspiracy theories and citing
scientific evidence including the U.S
Centers for Disease Control that
supports the theory that overwhelmingly
conclude that this coronavirus
originated in Wildlife off the top of it
at his head comes conspiracy theories on
the internet and even yesterday uh you
you saw some of his supporters some
people on the internet starting to
suggest that it was like a bio weapon
which which of course nobody said that
the president ever even said that uh
just said it may have come out of a lab
guy that didn't Tom go to Harvard
a guy uh very well educated Tom Cotton a
couple of days ago uh spouting and
conspiracy theory to the Chinese made
this virus up
Tom Cotton one of Donald Trump's
staunchiest allies in the Senate
suggested that the virus might have
originated in a high security
biochemical lab in China in the 1980s I
remember when the far left trafficked
and rumors about HIV having been
invented in CIA labs
the far right has now found its own
virus conspiracy theory
here's how CNN covered it in in print
this headline nearly 30 percent in the
U.S believe a coronavirus Theory that's
almost certainly not true
coronavirus almost certainly came from
an animal not a lab leak top scientists
argue lab elite covid-19 theory is like
something out of a comic book
virologists argue this is my favorite
one its origin is Up For Debate but it
wasn't made in a lab
and then finally
U.S energy Department assesses covid-19
likely resulted from a lab leak
there it is thanks to Cabot Phillips for
pulling all of those headlines there
that's how it is that's how it goes
we should apologize to the bats we
should apologize to the pangolins you
should not you if you're listening to
this show you're probably much more
open-minded but the Liberals out there
should all apologize to their crazy
conservative uncle and to their
intransigent conservative grandparents
or whoever they were all angry at so you
uneducated Rubes I can't believe you
think it's from a lab no the genetic
makeup of the virus it's so clear all
the experts say it's definitely not from
a lab
it's not just covet it's not just the
lab League Theory
this is how the news always operates
that's how the news is operating right
now
act accordingly the rest of the show
continues now
you do not want to miss it become a
member and use code Knowles kwles a
check out for two months free on all
annual plans daily word.com Knowles
you'll see you at the member block
[Music]
thank you